cctv
has helped immensely and with general
policing of the clubs with with the
doorman
uh contribute to the to the
well-being of margate
uh yeah i think it just has a bit of
violence and a bit of crime whatever
because
you don't know if you're being watched
or not but i don't think there's a lot
of action getting taken on cctv because
if there was then a lot more people
would be off the streets now
i know it's big brother it's one of
those big brother scenarios really i
mean everyone's saying
we're watching you and everything like
that but
people will be whinging if something did
happen it's not on camera at the end of
the day so and it helps
it's all good wearing like having cctv
cameras and wearing all these head
cameras
but what's going to happen when there's
somebody actually there getting hurt
like that person could end up dead and
there's nothing happening at that prison
time during
what i'm saying so it's like i just
think it would be better if there was
more police presence
i know it's like they shouldn't have to
do that but at the end of the day
because of the way it is
what else can you do probably the cctv
um yeah definitely and like the posters
and everything
yeah yeah brings up awareness doesn't it
i don't really think four's enough
yeah but yeah i think it's good that
they've got cctv
over the past 30 years
from pr to present time now has
degenerated
it hasn't got any safer whatsoever
despite all the ctd coverage
and the warnings about your own cameras
especially outside
the one two three local bars across this
area
nothing's safer on that we have seen
people here
outside this pub with noise fighting
and drugs are certainly involved at all
times
as for safeness just for yourself
gonna be wearing head cameras do you
think that's gonna be useful
yes i think so any security um
uh on hand like that you know obviously
they can see
record any incident that's happening and
yeah i think it's
invaluable yes maybe they'll take it
elsewhere or maybe they'll just stop but
either way
it will make the safe one a much safer
place to go out
we haven't seen much trouble there have
been events where
people have started trouble i mean where
you have
massive people and you have alcohol
it's bound to be expected but as a whole
the old majority of the security
is brilliant i mean no matter where you
are
like you're covered so it's because i
still don't think there's enough police
around
i still think there's a lot of young
children teenagers
you know that go around doing things
that they shouldn't be doing and i think
that's the whole reason it's not safe
you have local patrols of police coming
up and down the road all
right most of the night i mean like
occasionally they'll come and talk to us
as well
and then you have the door staff i mean
like from the areas
from just a bit further up the road and
outside the club
as well and across the road in that area
if anything kicks off in that area then
it is weird like as a
security team we'll go and deal with
that more placing
more places on the streets visible place
this summer's been really quiet i mean
everyone's just
everyone comes out now they're just
looking to have a good time and if
anyone that is looking to
like make a fuss people will come tell
us because they're about to have a good
time and that's
what everyone wants to come out now like
people seem to have overcome that part
stage where it's about going out and
having a few beers and like getting
around your mates people seem to
overbecoming that
and it's just all about the party now
and just everyone seems to want to have
a good time
come out enjoy themselves with their
friends at the end of the night get up
and then go
and get a taxi
you